well I have it on good authority that is
the people to whom I do preach and who
take the trouble to tell me about it
over many years that I make people think
I make them imagine see things that they
would not have seen before or ask about
things they hadn't thought about asking
before or even I have a capacity I hope
from time to time to lead people to what
the theologian calls and haha experience
or I never thought of that before what
an interesting notion I rejoice and
that's the same skill and the same
thrill that a teacher gets when somebody
finally gets it after you have tried to
put it before them that's the thrill of
preaching for me and I think I have the
ability to do that in many cases
well one thing I have to remind myself
at anybody else is that different people
have different aha moments at different
stages along the way some of which I may
be responsible for some of which I may
have absolutely nothing to do with but
I'm prepared to gamble that there is a
kind of common expectation out there and
my job is to try to conduct those
expectations rather than a soloist I
always think of myself as an orchestra
conductor I have all these instruments
to try to bring together in some
coherent sound and preaching for me is
very much like conducting it's not like
arguing as lawyers do or shouting as
politicians do it is trying to bring
together feelings and passions and ideas
that are already there trying to ignite
them in some intelligible way so the
conducting image from my musical
background is very much a part of how i
see preaching
well that's that's not an easy question
which is why you've doubtless put it to
me I hope that I will always be thought
of as a thoughtful preacher that I took
the life of the mind seriously but I
didn't toy with people's emotions that I
work very hard at trying to find the
right words to convey the right ideas
I'd like people to think that that's
what I did and that it did it well and
that i did over a long period of time in
a wide variety of places it would please
me to be thought of as effective both in
an exalted place like the memorial
church at harvard university and in a
very modest pulpit like South Pond
chapel in the dark woods of Plymouth
Massachusetts that I was able in those
remarkably different settings to make
people think and to cause them to react
and to respond that's what I'm
interested in and I would hope that
would be the legacy that I would leave
behind he made us think would be a very
nice epitaph